well everybody says there's gonna be an
epidemic of arthritis coming that's
because there's 80 million baby boomers
come along we all have 72 joints and
every one of them can have arthritis
right and so what's the problem here why
would 80 million baby boomers get
arthritis well because they listen to
medical doctors they exercise put a lot
of wear and tear energy under those
joints they told them don't take any
vitamins you could overdose so there's
no wrong and chills to kind of maintain
repair and then of course they say drink
plenty of water well you drink water or
sweat is more than water sweat is a soup
that contains all the known essential
nutrients 90 essential nutrients
unless you're only taking in 65 and then
it's it worse right or you're not
salting your foods he can't make stomach
acids not really well how much eat or
what cheese is what you absorb mm-hmm so
we have all these sort of ifs sort of
conditions does it have to be met here
before you get optimal amounts of
nutrients in your food you get Hospital
amounts of nutrients absorbed and you
get optimal amounts of nutrients
deposited in the bones well before we go
on and tell you how we're gonna do this
about July of 2002 in the New England
Journal of Medicine Harvard Medical
School did a meta study they looked at
over 300,000 people who had gotten joint
replacements from all over the world and
they said knee replacement hip
replacement shoulder replacement
unnecessary worthless worthless okay
and that's because it doesn't stop the
ongoing deterioration of the bone
doesn't stop the ongoing deterioration
of the joints and all the other places
right it just takes one joint or the two
joints that they're replacing throw them
in the garbage can and so they can't
kill anymore but it doesn't stop the
ongoing progress of the problems with
systemic problem and then four years
later the same group of doctors from
Harvard Medical School
look to the backs of these people and
they said oh surgery prior sciatica is
worthless and dangerous don't do it
they're talking about low back pain
degenerative disc disease of restless
leg syndrome peripheral neuropathies
burning numbness in the feet and
[Music]
as a result they say don't get surgery
for these problems what I always say is
give me 90 days gift not give doc 90
days and you are going to see one of
those miracles and basically what's
going to happen here is we are going to
support and promote maintenance repair
of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebra bone matrix and bone itself and
to do that you need a whole 90s
institution there were 16 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids 3
essential fatty acids and of course you
might need some anti-inflammatory stuff
which you can do with herbs and Roma
therapy oils and there certainly might
need some extra stuff if you have bone
to bone arthritis to again support
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebra bone Mason
bone cell you actually have to lay down
new bone matrix kind of like the rebar
the bone is a 10 like material ring lay
down new minerals and of course you just
can't take calcium SN enough because you
need more cofactors make it all work
your bones are made up of all 90
essential nutrients so I urge you to get
a hold of that trilogy of books let's
play doctor let's say herbal doctor in
the passport moment that are being
learned how to support and promote
maintance repair of cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue just between
the vertebra bone matrix and bone cell
so what do you do to do that is you take
one healthy bone and joint pack per
hundred pounds of body weight that's
going to give you one jar of the CM
cream to apply topically to joints for
pain relief great analgesic cream
topical use and this is going to give
you one large 240 count bottle of gluco
gel and one healthy start pack so if you
weigh 150 pounds of 210 pounds I would
take two of the healthy bone and joint
packs for month if you weigh 50 60
pounds I'd have you take one healthy
bone and joint pack if you're in a
peewee league you know kid sort of thing
and you have an ear problem shoulder
problem back home go ahead and take one
healthy bone and joint factor that's
gonna last two months four hundred pound
person is gonna last one month for a
200-pound person give or take a few
pounds it's gonna last two weeks because
their body weight and you're going to
get 245 nutrients in this package
including all 90 essential nutrients
plus the extra gluco gel to support and
promote maintenance repair
Lehman's Tenon's connective tissue disk
between the vertebra bone nation and
bonus L give doc 90 days let me tell you
this never fails if you're not getting
it even if the speed you wanted to guess
what happens here just means you got to
get it on a gluten-free diet maximize
your absorption you are not what you eat
you are what you absorb and then of
course there's also another possibility
no reason why I couldn't have both
problems as your bins restricting salt
in your diet you're not making stomach
acid is very difficult to absorb
minerals without stomach it's a very
absorb very difficult to efficiently
absorb b12 because the intrinsic factor
won't work out stomach acid is almost
impossible to digest proteins without
stomach acid
pepsin won't work and as a result you're
gonna be in a real struggle so you have
to deal with that salt your food to
taste you make sure that you're going
ahead and allowing the chief cells in
your stomach to make your stomach acid
and then of course you want to get on a
gluten-free diet and you will actually
allow your villi those little
finger-like projections to rebuild
regrow and you want to regain some of
that lost absorptive surface and of
course this happens progressively slowly
but surely over time if you're gluten
intolerant get hold of that cd0 killers
and learn how it affects you and all the
places the gluten is hidden give doc 90
days you will you will be happy and you
won't get knee surgery hip surgery backs
or your shoulder surgery what are what
are the peak surgeons to do
really care back